mais la vraie question d'ailleurs ça ça
va ça va interroger un petit peu
d'ailleurs le rapport à la politique
qu'on a aujourd'hui qui on veut voir
élus aujourd'hui des amateurs des gens
qui répondent à des castings politiques
ou des gens qui ont bossé je suis dans
un parti politique qui arrête pas de
parler du Mérite est-ce que les gens
qu'on a élu au Parlement européen ont
été méritants bah oui ils ont bossé ils
ont un bilan ouais al écoutez moi je
suis pas là pour faire la maîtresse
d'école en tous les cas la tête de l'IS
François Xabier bami il y a pas de doute
ah j'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu'il a
travaillé mais d'ailleurs honnêtement
même ses adversaires politiques qui on
le reconnaissent donc déjà qu'on éise
des gens sérieux des gens qui siègent au
Parlement bon je pensais à Monsieur
Bardella même à la région vous savez
comment on l'appelle onappelle bardépa
il n'est jamais là il ne vient pas à la
région il siège à peine au Parlement
européen la politique c'est quelque
chose de sérieux on voit ce qui se passe
avec les agriculteurs c'est des
questions qui sont aussi essentiellement
d'ordre européen pour ça il faut avoir
une constance il vous avoir une présence
du coup pourquoi avoir autant tardé pour
lancer François Xavier béamide dans la
campagne s'il y avait une reconnaissance
première à me répondre sur les réseaux
sociaux pour demander à-ce qu'il soit
rapidement nommé tête de liste parce il
a été trop tard non il a pas été trop
tard parce que quand on regarde par
rapport aux autres partis politiques
c'est quand même arrivé dans dans la
même fourchette de temps je crois qu'il
y en a même qui n'ont pas dernier il
plus que la majorité présidentielle bah
vous voyez non non je pense qu'il a été
nommé à temps puis surtout il est prêt
il est prêt parce que ça il a travaillé
c'est n pas un amateur contrairement à
ce que disait monsieur Macron de son
équipe il avait dit soyez fier d'êre des
moi je suis fire d'être avec des gens
qui sont des travailleurs est-ce que ces
élections c'est un peu kitouou pour
votre parti est-ce que ça peut être
l'élection de la dernière chance je P je
ne pense pas sincèrement parce que
l'avantage de l'élection européenne
c'est que c'est quand même des débats
qui parfois d'ailleurs sont assez
techniques et qui permettent justement
de montrer qui a du fond qui n'en a pas
donc je suis assez
confiante